me piden que encuentre todos los
factores de 120 y yo estoy bastante
emocionado por que con este vídeo vamos
a poder recordar todas las reglas de
divisibilidad de los números del 1 al 10
11 por ahí ok
encuentra todos los factores de 120 y
recuerda que un número es factor de 120
si nosotros podemos dividir al 120 entre
ese número y obtenemos de residuo cero
así que vamos a ponerlos aquí dos
factores
por eso y los vamos apuntando por aquí
todos los factores que encontremos ok
entonces pensemos en el ciento veinte
120 bueno de una manera muy fácil
podemos ver que es lo mismo que 1 % 20 1
% 20 y por lo tanto 120 tiene como
factores al 1 y asimismo a 120 entonces
vamos a ponerlos aquí 1 y además 120 y
lo voy a apuntar aquí para ir llenando
poco a poco todos los factores en orden
ascendente 1 y 120 ahora vamos a
preguntarnos si ciento veinte 120 tiene
mitad y bueno de una manera muy sencilla
podemos concluir que 120 si tienen mitad
de hecho su mitad de 60 120 tienen mitad
porque acaba en un número par y como el
0 es un número par entonces podemos
decir que el 120 es lo mismo que 2 por
60 2 por 60 o dicho de otra manera el 2
y el 60 el 2 y el 60 también son
factores del 120
2 y el 60 ahora tendrá tercera 120
tendrá tercera pues vamos a recordar el
criterio de divisibilidad del 3 un
número tiene terceras y la suma de sus
dígitos tiene tercera es decir 1
+ 20 esto es lo mismo que 12 30 es 33 y
3 tiene 3a de hecho 3 entre 3 me cabe
una vez
por lo tanto 120 también tiene 3a es
decir que a 120 lo podemos ver como 3 es
más primero déjeme quitar todo esto de
aquí a 120 lo podemos ver como 3 por
algo y si no recordamos por quién es ese
algo pues vamos a hacerlo 120 lo voy a
dividir entre 3 y dice 3 no cabe en una
ninguna vez entonces 3 por 4 3 por 4
estos en cuatro por tres es 12 y aquí
restó el 12 y entonces me queda 0 bajo
este cero y entonces me queda que es 3
cabe 0 veces en 00 lo pongo aquí y
entonces me residuo es 0 justo lo que
quería y además puso lo que acabamos de
concluir que 120 era divisible entre 3
por lo tanto cuando yo me tomo el 120
visto como 3 por algo ese algo es 40
por 40 ok entonces dejen quitar esta
operación que tengo aquí vamos a
quitarla para ir haciendo un poco de
espacio entonces estoy diciendo que el 3
y el 40 son factores de 120 por lo tanto
también los voy a poner aquí 3 y 40
también son factores del 120 ok pensemos
si el 120 tendrá 4a entonces vamos a ver
120 se podría escribir como 4 por algo
ok
recordemos el criterio de divisibilidad
del 4 un número se puede dividir entre 4
de manera exacta si los últimos dos
dígitos y sus últimos dos dígitos son
divisibles entre 4 en este caso sus
últimos dos dígitos son 20 y 20 claro
que es divisible entre 45 por 4 es 20
por lo tanto 120 también lo es ok pero
cuánto es 120 es lo mismo que 4 por algo
pero porque algo pues vamos a dividirlo
cuánto me dan 120
4 y dice 4 cabe en 10 veces por lo tanto
me agarró el 12 y digo 4 caben 12 3
veces 3 por 4 es 12 aquí los restos 12
menos 12 0 bajos de 0 y aquí me cabe 0
veces por lo tanto tengo de residuos 0
que es lo que yo quería y además estoy
diciendo que 120 es lo mismo que 4 por
30 que cuatro por 30 por lo tanto el 4 y
el 30 también son factores de 120 el 4 y
el 30 y el 30 son factores de 120 guau
son muchos pero tendrá quinta ok vamos a
borrar esto de aquí vamos a ver si 120
tiene quinta borremos esto de aquí y
pensemos en la quinta de ciento veinte
120 un número tiene quinta se acaba en
50 y 120 acaba en cero por lo tanto 120
lo podemos ver como 5 por algo porque
algo pues vamos a descubrirlo 120 lo voy
a dividir entre 5 y digo 5 por 2 es 10
entonces 2 por 5
10 aquí pongo el 10 los restos y dice 12
10 es 2
bajo este cero de aquí bajo el 0 por acá
y me quedan 5 cuántas veces caben 20
bueno pues 5 cabe cuatro veces en 20 4 %
es 20 y me sobra 0 de residuo
justo lo que yo quería 120 lo podemos
ver como 5 por 24 como 5 por 24 y tengo
de residuos 0 por lo tanto el 5 y el 24
también son factores de 120 el 5 y el 24
también son factores de 120 ok pues
borremos esta operación de aquí vámonos
vamos a pensar ahora si el 120 es
divisible entre 6 el 120 será divisible
entre 6 recordemos el criterio de
divisibilidad del 6 un número es
divisible en 36 si es divisible entre 2
y si es divisible entre 3 ok pero el 120
es divisible entre 2 y es divisible
entre 3 por lo tanto es divisible entre
6 el 120 lo podemos ver como 6 por algo
y creo que no está tan difícil dividir
120 entre 6
manera mental a ver pongámoslo en
nuestra mente 120 entre 6 es lo mismo
que 20 meses 6 por 20 es lo mismo que
120 esta división no estaba tan difícil
esto quiere decir que el 6 y el 20 son
factores también del 120 entonces los
voy a poner aquí el 6 y el 20 el 20
también ok pues parece ser que son todos
pero el 7 tendrá séptima 120 entonces
120 y bueno el criterio de divisibilidad
del 7 es un poco o mucho más bizarro que
el criterio de divisibilidad de todos
los demás de aquí por lo tanto qué te
parece si hacemos de una vez la división
para ver si tiene séptima 120 entre 7 ok
y dice 7 cabe en 12 una vez 1 por 77 12
menos 75 y entonces bajo este cero pongo
aquí el cero y digo 7 cuántas veces
caben 57 veces entonces 7 por 7 es 49 y
cuando yo restos 22 me queda de residuo
y qué crees tengo un residuo de uno por
lo tanto este no es un residuo de cero
lo que quiere decir que el 120 no se
puede dividir de manera exacta entre 7 o
dicho de otra manera el 7 no es un
factor de 120 fíjate
ya encontramos a uno que nos sirve el 7
no es factor de 120 y vamos a quitar
esto de aquí por lo tanto pues no
agregamos nada por acá vamos a pensar
ahora en el 8 en el 8 120 tendrá octava
y bueno recordemos el criterio de
visibilidad del 8 dice un número tiene
octava si sus últimos tres dígitos si
sus últimos tres dígitos son divisibles
entre 8 120 pues bueno vamos a fijarnos
y 120 es divisible entre 8 120 entre 8
8 cabe una vez en 12 1 por 8 es 8 y
cuando yo me tomo la resta 12 8 es 4
ahora bajemos este 0 de aquí y dice 8
por 5 8 por 5 45 por 8 40 y entonces
cuando yo me tomo 40 menos 40 ni residuo
es 0 perfecto esto quiere decir que el 8
si es factor de 120 o dicho de otra
manera el 120 lo puedo ver como 8 por 15
y entonces ya encuentre otros dos nuevos
factores el 8 y el 15 8 por aquí y 15
por acá y 15 el por acá ok y habrá más
pues pensemos un poquito en el 9 para
esto déjenme borrar esta operación que
tengo aquí volvemos esto de aquí no me
sirve y voy a pensar en el 9 criterios
de divisibilidad del 9 un número es
divisible entre 9 si la suma de esos
dígitos es divisible entre 9 entonces
uno más
pero esto es 3 y el 3 no es divisible
entre 9
de hecho 9 no cabe ninguna vez en 3 por
lo tanto 120 no lo puedo escribir como 9
por algo o de otra manera el 9 no es un
factor de 120 ok quitemos esto de aquí 9
no funcionó y vamos a pensar ahora en el
10 en el 10 y ese tiene un criterio de
divisibilidad muy fácil un número es
divisible entre 10 se acaba en 0 y 120
se acaba en 0 por lo tanto lo podemos
ver como 10 por algo 120 entre 10 esto
lo podemos hacer de una manera muy
sencilla me da 12 dicho de otra manera
el 10 y el 12 también son factores de
120 el 10 1 ya no me caben aquí el 10 o
déjame mejor hacer estos números un poco
más hacia la izquierda déjame tomar
todos estos aquí ok y los voy a mover un
poquito para acá los mueve mover de aquí
para que puedan poner el 10 y el 12
perfecto entonces pongamos al 10 al 10
también
voy a poner al 2 ok fíjate cómo estamos
haciendo los de orden ascendente tengo
el 110 120 el 2 y el 60 y aquí ya llegué
al 10 y al 12 por lo tanto solamente me
falta descubrir si el 11 es así el
número que está entre 10 y 12 es un
factor de 120 pero de una manera muy
sencilla podemos decir que no lo es
porque cuánto es 120 entre 11 es más
recordando la tarde de multiplicar del
11 11 por 11 121 11 por 11 por 11 es lo
mismo que 121 por lo tanto no creo que
haya ningún número que me dé de manera
exacta la división de 120 entre 11 pero
de todas maneras si no me crees vamos a
hacerlo cabe una vez 1 por 11-11-11 aquí
le pongo un signo de menos 12 menos 11
es uno bajo el 10 y no me cabe ninguna
vez 11 en 10 por lo tanto equipo de 10 y
tengo un residuo de 10 entonces esto no
me sirve el 11 no es factor de 120 y
ahora sí como llegué justo
medio ya puedo asegurar que todos los
factores de 120 son estos de aquí
déjenme tomar a esto de aquí lo voy a
quitar para decirte y concluir que
entonces todos los factores de 120 son
el 1 el 2 el 3 el 4 el 5 el 6 el 8 el 10
el 12 15 20 24 30 y 40 60 y 120 y son
todos wow es 120 tenía bastantes
factores